[Music]
god seems like a thousand years ago
i fought my way out of that cave
became iron man
realized i loved you
[Music]
i know i said no more surprises but
i was really hoping to pull off one last
one
the world has changed
[Music]
none of us can go back
[Music]
all we can do is our best
and sometimes the best that we can do
is to start over
[Applause]
i saw all these people die
i keep telling everybody they should
move on
some do
a lot of us
[Music]
even if there's a small chance
we owe this
to everyone who's not in this room to
try
we will
whatever it takes
whatever it takes
whatever it takes
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Music]
i like this one
[Music]
[Music]
staying on
hey miss potts
if you find this recording
don't feel bad about this
part of the journey is the end
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun than it sounds
food water ran out
four days ago
oxygen will run out tomorrow morning
i mean
when i drift off i will dream about you
it's always you
[Music]
this is gonna work steve
i know it is
because i don't know what i'm gonna do
if it doesn't
[Music]
hi uh is anyone home this is scott lang
we met a few years ago at the airport in
germany i got really big is this an old
message hey man yeah i know you don't i
know you know that it's a front door
that's me can you buzz me in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you